welcome to this video playing Carlo de
Moura from from Italy I'm playing the
Petrov and have no idea about the
opening but recently there's a new book
book released about this and yeah maybe
I'll even have a look at the petrol at
some point why not it's a very solid
opening and something like this is
certainly a theory g3 looks a bit
strange to me not sure what this really
okay not that that is terribly bad so
I'm find this very surprising ok let's
let's do something on the h4 so you
rarely able to do such active stuff in
this opening so let's get ahead normally
all this play 22 Castle long okay so if
i take now Bishop takes i have from job
but i do yeah i'll be able to anyway I
going go to d7 that's not a bad not a
bad spot so just f6 I can go to the
seven he gives us checking me sadness
relatively safe on Bishop h4 I just
played re5 and win this piece no matter
what check
and on the bishop move on don't play
each form it's not very convenient i
also have 95 and there's a very nice
position i usually have some problems
playing this guy it's very very decent
player i have fun wow this is really bad
two out of 12 i have with the chess
explained account yeah it's plated many
times with accounts before that before i
started to him to do the videos it's
very resourceful hmm ok i take this he
was going to give this check yeah well
this is not really working in it
and takes takes night and it's it's it's
a piece it's really jotted peace rocky a
takes Queen takes this 98 and if he
takes on g7 I'm just going to play let's
say rook the aid yeah come on Tate
that's not make it more complicated than
the necessary ok so be 6v6 and King b7
secure the the night or is it better to
to ignore this just dead ahead with H
form components that's page for you not
think ages about this it's probably good
anyway and take him
curious think if we need to take what
the f I've got through gate yet anyway
okay here i can also play this more
first get the night into the center
cannot drive it away from me five and
what next maybe be six can be safe now
this looks good I need to get the rookie
agent of the game and if the rook a
eight starts to play it's really just
it's just piece up for two pawns and he
cannot advance those pawns easily
because once my looks into play
advancing the pawns just weekends of the
King enormously and so come over this
looks like a victory against this
difficult opponent let's not spoil this
okay like a look h eight
threatened first maybe we can go get
from ya here son has taken away some
squares wow I should have thought about
this a bit longer at least a moment okay
bye drew cage friary cannot believe it
to that I think I can just take rook FHA
kingly 7mm I'm going away with the king
yeah yeah there's nothing nothing
terrible happening I hope I spending his
last moments him so be six or not still
thread at all just start to connect
rooks
yeah you really played this a very
strange our opening with them with g3
really am really weird ok wants to get
the Queen here to give a check
I can just go back here now you're i
play this move Queen d15b aid I really a
bit cautious here I feel just against
him so many times so that's it make sure
to really win this position now right
resigned all of any ideas now with both
rooks in the game it's it's really over
yeah and it was a very nice position
right right from the start I don't
really know when the the lines probably
here is just just castling Louis the
right way to go this is probably not a
mistake but it's not helping when anyway
95 is also good here okay with 27 yeah
how long has also didn't know we're
always already looks tried to quite
comfortable queen f5 is also not bad
okay let's just take this off f6 check
very nice now this this gives away
peaceful no doctor for fun sufficient
compensation but the the alternative is
like this year here and when age from
quite ugly quite ugly also nighty 50 an
additional threat computer wants to play
this ugliness something like that yeah
black has got a very convenient game ham
it's not immediately winning I guess
could you guess on about one pawn for
black now it's not not the end of the
world the chance way I did it was mostly
designed to confuse me better position
is just too bad yeah this
the right moves I was slightly irritated
at first tell me yeah it was a pretty
decent game then didn't commit any
substantial mistakes this cell seemed to
give blood gonna instantly good game he
should have really castled long earlier
alright thanks for watching